welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boston pixar's lightyear released a new
trailer for this epic sci-fi film that
toy story's buzz lightyear action figure
was based on turns out a david bowie
nash punk origin story filled with pixar
easter eggs and vivid photo realism that
steers just clear that uncanny valley of
chris evans chin dimple so i'm gonna
break this trailer down frame by frame
for all the cool details you might have
missed and hey if you wanna see us chat
about these kind of things live new
rockstars is gonna be live in chicago
this friday february 11th 8pm italia
hall ticket link in the description we'd
love to get to meet you in person let's
break this trailer down
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you so we opened with the
close-ups that we saw on the previous
trailer including buzz's dog tags
listing him as o positive and including
the star command sigil though this
version of the sigil has the ringed
planet behind the wings showing how this
crest will evolve over time passage of
time being a very big part of this story
as buzz suits up we see his reflection
in his home advisor it's just incredible
that they somehow removed the camera
from this reflection oh wait yes of
course it's all animated it's easy to
forget though with all this
photorealistic detail the curved
distortion of the visor the paint on the
number on the helmet chipping away and
later all the close-ups of the cockpit
controls grooves indentations where on
all the buttons just all little ways of
showing how this branch of star command
is not factory grade fresh off the
assembly line but rather worn down their
parts repurposed in the field to build
something new because they are marooned
buzz says a year of work for a
four-minute flight yes chris evans
voices this younger cinematic buzz which
makes sense considering in real life
other voice actors come and do the
voices of toys and games which is what
tim allen would be as the voice of the
toy version of buzz lightyear but kudos
to chris evans for not just doing his
captain america voice sounds like he's
really trying to emulate tim allen's
deeper register the base tones of the
tool man who spent two years and four
months in prison for trying to fly with
1.43 pounds of cocaine true facts folks
look it up imagine how much he snorted
before getting it down to a pound and a
half
they're gonna let me be santa but more
interesting is how buzz says a year of
work for a four minute flight
foreshadowing the time dilation that the
first teaser showed for this movie
buzz's short trip his orbital path will
cause him to leap forward in time so
that he will miss out on an even longer
period of time from the point of view of
the rest of star command making him a
lonely star man out of time the kind of
character chris evans has a knack for
plane i like how buzz tugs on his flight
suit as it rides up on him flattening
those wrinkles it's just a neat little
gesture showing how this is fabric it's
not the plastic of a toy his technician
is diaz voiced by efren ramirez aka
pedro from napoleon dynamite but then
buzz gets snatched well let's go find
out if this
now despite all the great photo realism
pixar still does just a great job using
classic cartoon blocking when it comes
to gags like this here keeping puzz's
helmet suspended in the air after the
grab now this green tentacle comes from
underground if you look closely in the
background there so rather than an
animal this may be a kind of carnivorous
plant life like a venus fly trap while
this seems to just be a recurring gag in
the movie no in pixar it could be
revealed to have some deeper agenda to
why it doesn't want them to leave this
planet because buzz is lying about what
they were hoping to find off the world
was cut off and we will explore that
more in the next clip after a full year
of being marooned on this planet
our first test flight is a go
let's get everyone home so yes buzz says
that this branch of star command was
marooned on this planet meaning they are
cut off from the rest of humanity and
buzz's test flight is part of a mission
to find home or to find a new home
because i theorize that star command
could be part of that earth evacuation
mission led by by enlarge and wall-e the
search for a new habitable planet for
all of mankind notice how the robots who
patrol the base and hand him the fuel
crystal as if they have to get approval
from these machines to use it has the
same evil red light photoreceptor like
hal in 2001 a space odyssey as auto on
the axiom so maybe they're marooned
because this ai didn't want them to
return to earth and now this green plant
monster is actually an analog for the
wonderful boot plant of wali natural
purity telling them that they are
already home but yes i know i'm just
going down the rabbit hole of the
headcanon nonsense that those of us who
believe all pixar movies are connected
and that the cars and cars murdered all
the humans of that universe but uh they
did i mean just think about it where are
the humans there's door handles on the
cars for humans to open mater has a
family of skeletons inside of him anyway
little detail here notice the satellite
dishes on the roofs of these base
structures are all pointed in different
directions so they're not all locked
into the same direct tv signal but
they're all just pointed in different
vectors to try to see what is out there
this perimeter fence does a pretty good
job keeping out the local wildlife in
this case an insectoid creature that
gets zapped you know what was running
through his mind though i can't help it
it's so beautiful
now buzz fuels his ship with this
crystal this is a reference to the
crystalline fusion he mentioned in the
first toy story i need to repair my
turbo boosters do people still use
fossil fuels or have you discovered
crystallic fusion well let's see uh we
got double a's i love this as the
shuttle lifts off ice falls from the
thrusters evoking ron howard's imagery
of the liftoff sequence in apollo 13.
this movie looks beautiful let's move on
good luck captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so diaz salutes buzz with this
little hop the same gesture and posture
as russell and up whenever he did his
salute fun fact russell's likeness was
based on pixar director pete sohn who in
this movie voices socks the cat robot
buzz hits the hyper launch button and
notice how his visor once he's in
hyperspace is retracted giving him that
more fish bully dome like he has with a
space ranger suit allowing him to
realize that there's actually no longer
any g-forces to struggle against and
just marvel at the beauty of the stars
streaming past him in the full rainbow
spectrum the same overwhelming light
that seems to also emit from that
crystal this being another reference to
2001 space odyssey the famous stargate
sequence in which going beyond the speed
of light fills our visuals with color
and textures and just feels like the
best acid trip now if you're full of
chivalry and really want to address
someone as lord and lady established
titles can make it official establish
titles is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english they let people buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land so they can call themselves a lord
or lady and in return established titles
commits to planting a tree it's a really
fun way to help preserve the beautiful
woodlands and biodiversity of scotland
while raising funds to support global
conservation efforts establish titles
work with the global charity trees for
the future and one tree planted to help
them plant a tree for every order plus
for those with scottish heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
roots your title pack comes with a
numbered plot and dedicated land on a
private estate in marley aberdeenshire
scotland an official certificate with a
crest you can even change your name on
credit cards plane tickets and dating
profiles go get yourself a couple pack
for you and your partner with adjoining
plots of land you can literally have
this gift ready in five minutes it makes
a great valentine's day gift in fact
they're running a valentine's day sale
right now and if you use the code
rockstars you get an additional 10 off
so go to establishtitles.com rockstars
to get your gifts now on to the next
clip
[Music]
hello buzz i am socks your personal
companion robot we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
okay in this section buzz suited up as
the space ranger explores the nearby
forest you can see that spherical
structure in the background the same one
that is on his base meaning this is a
forest around the base you can see green
vines snaking through the forest floor
may be part of the same vegetation
network as that grabby predator plant
but then we look up from another planet
at this looming starship through the fog
it's two-pronged almost like a giant
pincer or claw i assume this is the
battleship of emperor zerg doors whoosh
open on these zap troopers z-a-p maybe
an acronym for zerg assault patrol or
zerg armored police or something like
that they have a logo of something in
target crosshairs a released still
actually shows buzz's squad wearing
similar armor but with one chunky
shoulder plate meaning these might be
like stormtroopers from star wars like
they were soldiers who were enlisted to
fight for an empire that they don't
really swear loyalty too in this case it
could be part of these soldiers pasts or
what they fell into while buzz was time
dilated away or maybe armor that buzz's
group wears is a disguise on a mission
as the heroes do in pretty much every
other star wars movie we see buzz
removing socks from a padded case his
eyes closed like a teddy breakspin i
love how all of sox's joints just look
popped on clearly a dividing line
between the limb and his torso and a
seam runs down the center of his head
where he can see the fur was just
stapled on in pieces just little extra
steps that the pixar design team took to
make socks look extra artificial and i
like how wind socks scares buzz he jumps
into a karate pose just as buzz did when
woody first scared him there's a shot
from the first teaser of zerg walking
among his z-stamped robots all that
attention so maybe zerg resorted to
using killer robots after his zap
troopers proved disloyal and this
trailer gives us a much clearer look at
zerg or at least his robot form compared
to his toy form in toy story 2 this
robot's way taller it doesn't have a
cape and walks on two legs instead of
rolling around so the zerg robot that
buzz faces in this movie might actually
just be a robot form that's controlled
remotely by the realzer and we will see
if this movie maintains a toy story 2
backstory of zerg being revealed as
buzz's father allah empire strikes back
but there is a subtle darth vader
parallel here in the way zerg cuts off
buzz's exit in this red lit room evoking
vader's kill box as the rebels tried to
escape onto the tantive iv in rogue one
i was like how buzz is given an inner
dome light with his blue green red
lights emitting the soft glow and his
arm panel is hatched open to access his
comms just like the buzz lightyear
action figure does when he tries to
radio to star command then this shot of
zerg stomping toward buzz's squad now
all clad as space rangers the squad
includes buzz's friend alicia izzy
hawthorne voiced by kiki palmer the
mustachioed one is voiced by taika
watiti and the shorter one is voiced by
dale souls from orange is the new black
so this moment with socks in the cockpit
it looks like it might be stitched
together from two different moments one
when buzz catches the cat robot another
where sox clings to his leg as he and
the cockpit are covered in confetti so
maybe socks snuck aboard hidden in a box
as a birthday surprise for buzz
immediately regarding it then buzz is
tackled by a zap trooper on this foggy
planet but based on the other still
again this might be izzy in the armor
actually doors close on more zap
troopers as they carry these laser
staffs and then a close-up of socks
where we see he has a collar tag and the
same style as buzz's dog tags making
them both in a way property of star
command merch in a box as buzz's legacy
will become as an action figure then the
shadow of the zerg robot looms in on
buzz at this dead end buzz is clutching
something in his hand maybe something he
stole from zerg this dead end has
scratches on the wall like it's a place
some past unlucky people tried to escape
this area also has some yellow heavy
machinery looking a lot like the loaders
of the aliens maybe what buzz will use
to tell zerg get away from her you [ __ ]
and i like how zerg's blaster has these
three green barrels just like the gun of
the toy version that fired little balls
from that rotating chamber moving on
okay now here is a shot of what i think
is the real zerg slamming his control
panel in rage because unless this chair
is also massive this is probably not the
huge robotic form of zerg that we've
been seen elsewhere in the trailer i
think this is the actual guy at the
console from which he operates the robot
remotely because on all those screens
look like parts of the robot then the
shot of izzy as she's being attacked by
this winged insectoid beast and then
hoisted in the air attached to them
though is that same green serpentine
tentacle it looks like it has some leafy
parts to it so i think this winged beast
was attacking izzy and now that
underground tentacle light form is
actually saving her from the beast i
really do think this thing is just
trying to give them all a hug then a
shot of izzy throwing this baton or
weapon out at us it looks like she's in
the back of a vessel that is currently
propping up that massive collapsing
structure that buzz and the other ranger
slid down under so she might be tossing
this to buzz to help him or give him
something to prop it up then buzz's
shuttle passes through one of these
rings that we saw in the last teaser
there's three of these all part of his
charted journey this final ring looks
like a portal barrier that he crashes
through maybe indicating a kind of
dimensional rift that allows him to leap
forward in time be time dilated okay on
to the final clip
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
so buzz plops down in bed with a sleep
mask as socks runs through sleep sound
options including whale calls which pete
stone really underlines the delivery
there clearly a nod to dory's whale
speak and finding nemo maybe he only
speaks whale
[Music]
what are you doing
i like how sox's white noise pose is
essentially a hissing cat he goes full
out trembling as he does this no
possible way you'd be able to sleep with
this thing next to you i'm super pumped
for this movie i think it's gonna be a
lot of fun and hopefully disney will
allow it to actually come out in
theaters please we gotta see this on a
big screen now you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eea boss
follow new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
to infinity and
and
and
i'm
i'm not really alive
[Music]
you